MAX WOGHIREN: Hi everyone.
My name's Max and I'm an
engineer on the Chrome team.
Today I'd like to show
you my favorite way
to build amazing Android
and iOS applications using
web technologies.
You can install Chrome
apps on mobile devices.
First though, a
bit of background.
Many of you are aware that
you can build applications
for Android and iOS that
heavily leveraged the web view
component, to the extent
to your application
is almost entirely built with
HTML, JavaScript, and CSS.
Now to be clear, these
are apps that you still
install from the app store.
They have an icon
on the home screen
and full access to
device capabilities,
like any other app.
But they're built
using web technologies.
We often call these types
of applications hybrid
because they are a blend of
web and native technologies.
On Android, one drawback
of hybrid applications
is that web views on
older versions of Android
can be a bit limited.
Chrome has seen a ton of
improvements on Android,
especially over the past year.
But running on old
web views means
that you can't take advantage
of those improvements.
That's where the Intel crosswalk
open source project comes in.
The crosswalk project provides
an embed double Chromium web
view for Android versions as
far back as Ice Cream Sandwich.
Using Crosswalk,
hybrid applications
can run on the latest
version of Chromium,
regardless of Android versions.
Similarly on iOS, the web
view has seen great updates
since version 6.
And now, with iOS
8, the web view
will match the full capabilities
of the Safari browser.
And what does this all mean?
Well, it means that it's
finally possible to build
hybrid apps that use
a modern web view
and run on almost every
Android and iOS device released
within the past three years.
Now here's an HTML5 Canvas based
game called Pop Pop Win running
on the crosswalk web view.
Smooth as silk thanks to a
hardware accelerated canvas.
This wasn't possible year ago.
Nowadays, hybrid apps
can use technologies
like WebGL, WebRTC, Web
Audio, accelerated 2D Canvas,
and modern web tool
kits like Polymer
all at maximum performance
without the need
for browser polyfills.
And it gets even better.
Hybrid applications are not
limited to just using web APIs.
Since these apps are
also native apps,
you'll have full access to all
Android and iOS device APIs,
such as identity, Cloud
Messaging, notifications,
payments, Bluetooth, sockets,
cameras, and much more.
Here's an app written
using Polymer showing off
some nice animations,
running polyfill free.
So it's clear that there's a
lot to like about hybrid app
development.
But how do you get started?
Well, over a year
ago our team started
contributing to the popular
open source hybrid application
Toolkit Apache Cordova.
We also took a look
at the amazing work
being done with Chrome
packaged apps for desktop.
So, in January, we released
a developer preview of a tool
called CCA, which allows you to
build hybrid mobile apps using
the Chrome packaged app format.
Now one of the most convenient
aspects of web development
is it's extremely rapid workflow
and short feedback loop.
No compiling, you can
just make a change,
and see it right away.
Sadly, with hybrid apps,
like all native apps,
you do have to wait
for compilation.
So you lose that
rapid feedback loop.
Our companion tool, the Chrome
app developer tool for mobile,
changes everything.
Let me show you how it works.
I've connected to
my device via USB,
but you can also use Wi-Fi.
On the device I'm
running the App Dev Tool.
Now I can type a command to
push my app to the device
and watch for changes.
You can see that the app is
transferred to the device
and launched within
the App Dev tool.
Now that settings button
in the top right corner,
it's a little small, so let's
make it a little bigger.
I can open up the CSS file.
And once I do, we'll scale
it up by a factor of 2.
Once that's done,
I'll save the file.
The change has been detected
and pushed to the device
and the app is relaunched.
The settings button's bigger,
looks a little better,
so we'll have our designers
make a bigger icon.
Now let's go into
that settings menu.
OK, it's not working.
So let's look into that.
I know the click
handler's in weather.js
so I'll open that file.
Right, I commented
that out earlier.
So let's un-comment
that and save the file.
Once again, that
change is detected,
and hopefully once it loads--
Yep, settings now work.
No recompilation.
I can continue to
iterate on my mobile app
smoothly and instantly.
We're also working on
supporting the same edit refresh
workflow on Chrome
Dev editor, which
you can learn about during a
live talk here at Google I/O.
So there you have it.
Chrome apps a great way
to target many platforms,
including Windows, Linux, Mac,
Chrome OS, Android, and iOS.
With Chrome apps
on mobile devices
you can leverage all the latest
and greatest hybrid application
techniques, easier
than ever before.
We're excited to
see what you build.